so oft wie möglich gehen sie schaukeln
agnes und amir zwischen ihnen liegen 73
jahren
ohne dich von rammstein ist ihr
gemeinsames lied geworden seit 50 jahren
wohnten es in ihrer berliner wohnung
seit dem tod ihres mannes vor vielen
jahren wohnt sie ganz allein täglich
kommt ein ambulanter pflegedienst zu der
über 100 jährigen doch um gesellschaft
und den ganzen rest kümmert sich an mir
der junge iraner ist vor sieben monaten
bei ihr eingezogen
ich wollte aber auch nicht in eine in
allen heimen wollte ich nicht und david
binnig trieben gekommen ja und ich
suchte nach einer wohnung
und ich habe eine anzeige
wir brauchen eine frau die sich unsere
ohne kommerz und ich habe mir gedacht
mach meine frau was kann eine frau tun
das ich nicht kann
[Gelächter]
zusammengebracht hat sie uwe eberlein
ein langjähriger freund von agnes seine
idee eine wg zwischen jung und alt
kostenlos wohnen gegen gesellschaft
damit es nicht ins heim muss es bewarben
sich 22 frauen und an mir
gesagt ich sehe wie die wohnung hsv hat
ja kein eigenes zimmer so aber von
vornherein gesagt ich mach das ich
bleibe hier wenn ihr das wollt und und
ohne bedingungen zu stellen also ganz
ganz rühren amir schläft auf dem sofa
hat nur einen schrank im wohnzimmer
er wollte nichts verändern damit es sich
weiter in ihrer wohnung zurecht findet
sagt er wegen seiner homosexualität ist
er aus dem iran geflohen macht in berlin
eine ausbildung zum flieger
von allem die ich
kennengelernt habe halt gut gelernt ja
hat eigentlich gut gelegen ich lerne
es war freundschaft auf den ersten blick
an ihr führt agnes in die shisha bars
oder spendiert ihr pizza
seit er da ist ist im leben der
101-jährigen immer was los
ich habe keine familie in deutschland
und das tut mir auch gut wenn ich wenn
ich weiß dass hier man auf mich in der
wohnung warten das ist gut dass ich weiß
dass du auf mich wartet ja ja ja und du
kümmert sich du kümmerst dich um ich
mache ich ja
sie kümmern sich umeinander fertigmachen
zum spaziergang denn an mir hat heute
frei
denn das
überall so weit die ich
machen
so hat muss mit über 100 einen neuen
freund gefunden
[Musik]
und an mir in seiner neuen heimat eine
familie
[Musik]